hemos recibido más detalles sobre la
solución que propone la administración
del presidente obama para salvar los
bancos por lo que creo que este es un
muy buen momento para analizar lo que
están proponiendo y ver si podemos
llegar a alguna conclusión para
simplificar el problema original aquí
tenemos un banco y digamos que tienen
solo un bien que es tóxico y por el cual
pagaron originalmente 100 dólares así
que este es el valor original en libros
de este bien y yo sé que los bancos
tienen muchísimos más bienes que uno
solo pero estoy simplificando de más
esto para poder analizarlo con más
facilidad aunque yo sé que la proporción
de préstamo pudo haber sido mayor
digamos que se quedan con un equilibrio
de 40 dólares y pidieron prestados los
60 dólares faltantes para comprar este
bien y por supuesto este bien de acá
está respaldado por hipotecas tóxicas y
les recomiendo que vean vídeos del daño
colateral y obligaciones y respaldos de
hipotecas y también los vídeos
relacionados con el plan de rescate
original
ya que ahí mencioné los problemas de la
liquidez el problema aquí es que este
banco tiene que pagar sus deudas por lo
que necesitan de deshacerse de estos
bienes para tener efectivo y pagarlas
pero el problema aquí es que si ellos
venden sus bienes y aquí imaginemos que
todos saben que esto no vale esos 100
dólares pero este banco no quiere
deshacerse de estos bienes por menos de
60 dólares ya que si ellos venden esto
por cualquier cosa que sea menor a 60
dólares van a tener un equilibrio
negativo y se verá afectado el valor en
sus libros digamos que este es el único
bien que tienen y que lo quieren vender
por 50 centavos cada dólar entonces
venderán todo por 50 dólares así que se
tendría esta realidad
aquí se tienen 50 dólares
pero se deben 60 dólares
por lo que no queda nada para el
equilibrio y de hecho se tendría que ir
a la bancarrota y por lo tanto se
volvería un banco insolvente por lo que
se entiende que el banco no quiera
vender sus bienes por menos de 60
centavos por dólar y el problema aquí es
que lo más que están dispuestos a pagar
las personas los inversionistas por
estos bienes en este momento no son
siquiera los 60 centavos por dólar
he leído artículos en donde se nota que
las personas apenas están dispuestas a
pagar 30 centavos por dólar por estos
bienes tóxicos así que vamos a
escribirlo aquí porque esto es
importante aquí está lo que el banco
quiere
quiere algo que sea mayor a 60 centavos
por dólar y en este caso son 100 dólares
por lo que querrán 60 dólares y los
inversionistas están dispuestos a pagar
los inversionistas pagarían
hasta donde yo entiendo sin ninguna
intervención gubernamental los
inversionistas quieren pagarte 20
centavos o menos por dólar así que esto
está completamente desconectado el banco
no quiere vender por nada que sea menor
a 60 centavos ya que si el banco vende
por menos de 60 dólares se va a la
bancarrota y por otro lado los
inversionistas saben que estos bienes
son tóxicos
cada día los negocios respaldando estos
bienes están llendo a la bancarrota y no
se puede encontrar documentación que
respalde a estos préstamos de estos
bienes tóxicos algunos fueron préstamos
ninja que no tenían trabajo estas
personas ni respaldo y aún así se les
prestó dinero incluso a cuestiones
fraudulentas por lo que los
inversionistas están notando el tremendo
riesgo que hay en estos bienes y por eso
es que están ofreciendo tan poco dinero
30 centavos o menos por lo tanto el
vendedor está queriendo obtener mucho
más dinero del que está dispuesto a
ofrecer el posible comprador por lo que
nada ocurre así que estos bienes tóxicos
están ahogando el sistema ya que los
bancos no es que no puedan ver
pero no quieren venderlos a menos de
cierto precio ya que si lo venden al
precio del mercado pues se van a ir a la
bancarrota por lo que el gobierno estado
tratando de encontrar diferentes
soluciones a esta situación encontrar
una manera de poder sacar estos bienes
tóxicos de los bancos sin que éstos se
vayan a la bancarrota y la versión
original del tarp 1 era que el gobierno
esencialmente compraba estos bienes
tóxicos por los 70 centavos de dólar y
en esa realidad si se llegaran a comprar
estos bienes a 70 centavos por cada
dólar pues estos bienes
tendríamos 70 dólares aquí
el banco debe 60 dólares
y aún les quedaría un poquito de
equilibrio
10 dólares
pero aquí lo importante es que el banco
podría pagar más de sus obligaciones
permanecer con liquidez y pues poder
continuar con su trabajo unos días más
esperando que mejore la economía y todos
se dieron cuenta que el tarp era hasta
cierto punto un fraude porque cuando se
hace esto si el precio de mercado
realmente es de 30 centavos por dólar y
se estaban pagando 70 centavos por este
mismo dólar este start 1
y el gobierno paga esto estos 70
centavos por cada dólar
el gobierno está sobre pagando 40
centavos por cada dólar en este caso el
gobierno le está escribiendo un cheque
por 40 dólares a los dueños de esta
compañía en este caso los inversionistas
y justamente estas son las mismas
personas que nos metieron en estos
problemas así que porque se les debería
de estar regalando dinero simplemente
para rescatarlos de sus propios errores
y ya hablaremos en otros vídeos al
respecto así que la nueva iteración a la
que han llegado es que permítanme
dibujar las circunstancias originales
tenemos este elemento aquí el cual
originalmente fue comprado por 100
dólares
y pidieron prestado 60 dólares para
comprarlo
y quedan 40 dólares de equilibrio
el nuevo plan es el gobierno dice bueno
yo como gobierno pues no estoy en una
posición para saber exactamente cuál es
el valor real de estas acciones o de
estos bienes ya que no somos
administradores de fondos de cobertura
ni nada por el estilo simplemente somos
burócratas y en efecto muy probablemente
estaríamos pagando de más por estos
bienes que no valen tanto ya que estas
personas son inteligentes y si ellos no
están dispuestos a pagar más de 30
centavos por dólar de este bien pues
bueno nosotros estaríamos pagando de más
y no sería justo para los contribuyentes
así que el nuevo plan de geithner es
asociarse con inversionistas privados y
la forma en la que están sugiriendo que
eso se lleve a cabo es imaginar que
bueno eso es algo que yo he estado
leyendo en los periódicos últimamente y
los números sin duda pueden cambiar pero
la idea fundamental es esta los
inversionistas privados podrían
e invertir 7 dólares así que esto es de
inversionistas privados
este solo contribuirá con otros 7
dólares la misma cantidad que
contribuyen los inversionistas privados
así que el tesoro contribuye con otros 7
dólares
y la reserva federal va a prestar lo que
resta del dinero necesario para comprar
estos bienes 14 menos 100 la reserva
federal va a tener que prestar 86
dólares la reserva federal fed va a
contribuir va a prestar 86 dólares y
esta entidad cuando fue capitalizada
originalmente tendrá 100 dólares de
efectivo quizás podría ser un poquito
menos pero eso es lo que dijimos que
debería tener así que esos 86 dólares es
un préstamo el tesoro hizo una inversión
directa de 7 dólares los inversionistas
privados hicieron una inversión directa
también de 7 dólares y ahora esta
entidad puede ir a comprar estos bienes
y al menos lo que yo entiendo que quiere
hacer el gobierno aquí es que los
inversionistas privados van a determinar
el precio así que el inversionista
privado va a decir mira yo creo que esto
de aquí vale 70 centavos por dólar y
supongamos que esas personas son las que
están dispuestas a pagar lo más que se
pueda por estos bienes ya que habrá una
subasta y el inversionista privado
asociado con el tesoro trataran de pagar
lo más que se pueda por estos bienes
digamos que ellos pagan no sé digamos
que 100 dólares para ahorrarnos los
cálculos así que este efectivo va a este
banco por lo que ahora tendrá 100
dólares en efectivo y se tiene el viento
-que psico acá
y ustedes podrían decirme oye eso está
muy loco no es posible que esto lo haga
un inversionista privado y tienen razón
vamos a corregir esta cantidad de los
100 dólares y digamos que se pagan 60
dólares ya que recordemos que los bancos
no estaban dispuestos a deshacerse de
este bien por menos de 60 centavos por
dólar así que para que esto funcione
pues se tiene que pagar mínimo lo que
está pidiendo el banco imaginemos que se
pagan 60 dólares por esto aquí tienen el
bien y les quedan 40 dólares ya que
solamente se pagaron 60 dólares por este
bien y bueno esto es por como yo estoy
establecido el ejemplo seguramente eso
está diseñado para que no les quede
ningún sobrante pero sigamos usando
estos números para seguir con la idea y
no complicarnos con cálculos y los
inversionistas privados dicen bueno ok
esto está bien tomé una decisión educada
y se decidió ponerle un precio de 60
centavos por dólar a esto mi pregunta
para ustedes es por qué estas mismas
personas que antes de este plan decían
que esto no valía más de 30 centavos por
dólar
estarían
ahora dispuestas a pagar 60 centavos el
doble de lo que originalmente habían
encontrado como precio aquí hay un par
de respuestas
la respuesta inocente es que el gobierno
recibiría el primer golpe en caso de que
esto fallara si estos bienes terminarán
al final valiendo sólo 30 centavos de
dólar lo más que puede perder el
inversionista en esta situación son los
7 dólares que ya invirtió nada más el
resto de la pérdida va a tener que ser
sobrellevada por la reserva federal y el
tesoro este préstamo de la reserva
federal no es recurrente lo que
significa que si esta entidad no puede
devolver el préstamo la entidad que hizo
el préstamo no puede ir a reclamarle a
los inversionistas oa los accionistas
todo lo que puede hacer quien prestó el
dinero es recibir el bien si este bien
termina valiendo nada pues no recibe
nada y no recuperará nada de su préstamo
por lo que en esa situación el
inversionista privado pues tiene todas
las ganas si este bien por el que se
pagó 60 dólares termina valiendo 80
dólares
los 20 dólares extra serán divididas y
repartidas entre el tesoro y el
inversionista privada
así que vamos a dibujar esta situación
la hoja de balance luce así pagaron 60
dólares por este bien pero ahora este
bien vale 80 dólares así que este es un
escenario bastante positivo y recordemos
que teníamos 40 dólares sobrantes en
efectivo como habíamos establecido el
problema originalmente por lo que se
deben 86 dólares
al pez
y la reserva federal que oficialmente
está separada del tesoro
y el equilibrio es dividido o repartido
entre el tesoro y el inversionista
privado así que cuánto queda de
equilibrio aquí tenemos 120 dólares
menos los 86 del préstamo nos queda un
equilibrio de 34 dólares
y se va a repartir cincuenta y cincuenta
por lo que serán diecisiete dólares para
el tesoro y diecisiete dólares para el
inversionista privado
y si vemos la inversión original del
inversionista privado fue de 7 dólares y
ahora recibió 17 dólares por lo que tuvo
una buena ganancia y ese es el escenario
positivo ahora veamos el escenario
negativo en donde la inversión original
termina valiendo los 30 dólares
recordamos que les habían quedado 40
dólares de efectivo y ahora de pronto
vemos que el préstamo que recibimos de
la reserva federal de 86 dólares
en este caso mis bienes valen menos que
mis obligaciones por lo que desaparece
mi equilibrio así que en esta situación
mala el inversionista privado puso 7
dólares y pues no recibió nada los
perdió y esto luce como un escenario
malo en el caso positivo pasamos de 7
dólares a 17 dólares y en el caso
negativo pasamos de 7 dólares a 0 y esto
puede aumentarse mucho más dependiendo
de cómo funcionen todo esto pero aún
permanece la pregunta si un
inversionista está convencido de que
estas cosas valen 30 centavos y que no
hay posibilidad de que valgan más que
eso
incluso cuando esté la posibilidad de
participar de esta manera
desproporcionada en la que si es el caso
positivo ellos obtienen mucha ganancia y
no tanto de la pérdida que yo creo que
esto por si mismo está mal el gobierno
no tendría por qué estar subsidiando a
fondos de cobertura y otras entidades
privadas si el inversionista privado
está convencido de que el valor de esto
está cercano a los 30 centavos y no se
acerca para nada a los 60 centavos que
pide el banco la pregunta después porque
participaría en esto siquiera si sabes
que vas a perder dinero pues no se
debería participar esto en lo absoluto y
me acabo de dar cuenta que me estoy
quedando sin tiempo así que continuaré
con esto en otro vídeo y yo creo que el
siguiente vídeo ustedes lo encontrarán
algo perturbador nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo